welcome back to the Sarah Jamie show now
my next guest has sold over 2 million
books worldwide he is owen Colfer you'll
know him of course from the Artemis Fowl
series and the young people's fiction
book fantasy book eight books it was
huge
he's here with me now I mean it's lovely
to see you it's love I think everybody
can see me yeah lovely to be R thanks
Robin and also misspelt was such a huge
success as I said you know over 2
million books sold read worldwide is a
huge part of your life what was it over
15 years it was it was I went from kind
of early middle age with one baby to
actual actual middle age with a grown-up
child and teenagers so it was it was a
huge part of my life yeah and I
understand that there is this film the
first film from Disney coming out later
this summer which how do you feel about
that because it must be so interesting
as an author to have written eight books
yeah it's very personal to everybody
that reads it they have their own vision
in their head of Artemis Fowl and in his
world what's it like to see it translate
to the big screen it's strange and what
Kenneth Branagh of course is a bit of a
genius so I was quite happy and then
they said well Judi Dench is in it and
she's gonna do an Irish accent so I
thought well I know she says so they
played me this little clip of Judi Dench
made up as a fairy saying a very
innocuous Irish phrase which was top of
the morning and it was the most
aggressive use of that phrase I thought
she's fantastic
so she could play anybody I think she's
just a genius actress so it's got your
approval you involved in the process I'm
not really I did a couple of cameos they
may use one they may not my advice would
be cut those guys do you hope so I hope
so because they just pretty much like I
am here they said just don't look at the
camera I know you do is look at the
camera like 20 cameras everywhere you
looked there was a guy with the cameras
so I was terrible oh did you did you
share any screen time with Dame Judi
Dench
no no I haven't actually met Dame Judi
yet she was never there when I was there
but hopefully we will bump into each
other
at some point and well that's exciting
and that's happening this summer is
released by Disney but you're here today
to talk about your new novel high fire
which is an older angel age range to
Artemis Fowl it's young adults no this
is an adult adult I would like to stress
no okay he's no kids I would say 18 and
up I really okay
I would because it's quite I mean
there's a lot of explosion this is some
swearing it's all the stuff hard
drinking that I bracket in it I've been
holding all this in for like 20 years
while I was writing about leprechauns so
now it's all it's like one big long
expletive book we say that actually the
news industry we'd love to make a show
about what goes on in the breaks in turn
I've seen so that must have been how it
was for you writing for children in
fantasy and you know to have outtakes
and read things happening or unusual yes
yeah it's great I mean it all I kept all
of that and it went in there and this
actually started as a kids book but
somewhere along the line of the first
few chapters the Dragons started
drinking vodka and I was like where does
that come from obviously my subconscious
knows something I don't know and then I
had to go back and make it another book
yeah so it's definitely not for kids but
if you grew if you grew up reading
Artemis in the in the 90s or 2000s I
should say I'll be always enough to read
this you should be all love now and it's
interesting isn't the fantasy journey of
genre because Lord of the Rings The
Hobbit when that was translated to the
big screen it really became I mean
really became mainstream that's exactly
right and then Game of Thrones as well
made it okay for adults to like dragons
and fairies and fantasies this is the
evolution of this yeah I'm trying to
bring dragons into noir fiction where
they haven't really been before and
Dragons usually are quite noble or else
they're you know there are these vast
creatures that just soar over your town
and just obliterate the John Lewis not
that the one that I haven't seen that
one is he a nice guy he's quite cute and
he sneezes and sets fire to everyone I
just hate him and he's really cuddly a
nice yeah that sounds like one of my
sons I'm not gonna say but this guy is
kind of he's more like a grumpy grandad
the swamp who just happens to be a
dragon so he's a bit more human than the
vast animals were used to seeing on TV
it's out today I mean some of the
reviews a joyous fantasy for grown-ups
true detective meets Swamp Thing that
was from The Guardian The Telegraph
southern gothic romp is like Artemis
Fowl for grown-ups
if you're waiting for the next game of
Thrones novel this fills the gap its
second Louisiana is that I've always
wanted that in one of my reviews fills
the gap but no I know yeah it's said in
Louisiana in the swamps up on the Pearl
River where they have a legend
pretty much like Nessie here where
there's supposed to be this Bigfoot kind
guy there and people go on tourists
looking for him so I thought if you were
a dragon and you wanted to be not seen
we're better than here because if you
are seen no one's gonna believe it
anyway so he's hiding out with the
alligators and he's watching cable TV
and drinking vodka enjoying his final
days I mean why not what else would the
jacket be doing what else can you do
well you can't get a good Guinness in
Louisiana
oh really vodka is the next best okay
okay so that's out now and obviously I
have to talk about Artemis fire because
I've got so many people getting in touch
will you ever return to that or is that
done and definitely looks I think it's
probably Artemis is done and dusted I
think but I am doing a series with his
little brothers two twins so I probably
do I've done one I'd probably do three
that they're a little funnier I think
they're they're like gothic comedies so
yeah there that's going really well but
Artemis just to make sure cuz I'm very
weak and I thought if enough people
pressure me I will I'll bring it back so
well I did in the first twins book is I
sent him on a five-year mission to Mars
okay so you've got five years I've got
five years so good to meet you and good
luck with the book high-five which is
out today thanks Sarah Jane